bye
a lot of the data sources that power the
site
and so if you think about the requests
that come in
from hulu.com and various devices
a lot of them end up touching our
services
and our services are on the critical
path for a lot of a lot of those
requests
what is so i don't know if uh
we're pretty well known at this point
more so than a couple years ago
but uh we are an online streaming
company
so uh we provide a lot of
premium content like television episodes
and whatnot
and movies uh available online so we
have a lot of licensing deals with
our content partners fox abc nbc
so that way you can see a lot of uh
currently airing shows right on hulu.com
on various devices
and more eloquently we help people find
and enjoy the world's premium content
when where and how they want it
and a little bit more about the tech
team actually
as i mentioned we have a lot of services
that we develop we're try and embrace
the service oriented
architecture methodology and
we also follow the unix philosophy so
if you're familiar with it it's pretty
much
that we try and keep our services
encapsulated in terms of functionality
don't
do too much at one time just kind of
focus on a core
problem and solve it above and
going along with that we have a lot of
small teams that are focusing on these
different problems
and making sure that we can actually
get a really good solution that scales
well has
you know good performance and
can handle the traffic and
going and going along with that also
we're really focused on using the right
tool for the job
and as we'll see soon we found that
cassandra
fit our needs pretty well for some of
these services
and you know there's no barrier in terms
of
uh you know business bureaucracy or red
tape for us to
use cassandra it's it's what works built
for us
and they carry us through a lot of
different services we can
use what actually solves our solves our
problems
and finally we do a lot of
cross-team development you know we're
all
developing services and there's a lot of
common functionality
and there's also some uh
devops related devices so if you go to
hulu.com and you're logged in
as you're browsing the pages you can see
progress indicators showing oh
hey you watched this episode or you know
you're only halfway through another
this is all provided via the huge shop
service
and the other fun feature of cubeshop is
a session carrier so as you're watching
you know
a show on a laptop or something maybe
uh you know it's time to head out time
to head to work so
as you leave the house you know you take
your phone
as soon as you get on the bus you take
the phone out
and go to the hulu app you can take up
right where you left off
and that's all provided via the service
api
uh things that he shop does not cover is
a lot of the analytics work
part of the process is q shop is really
related more
to the real-time requests that come in
and we leave the analytics work to a
entirely separate pipeline
which is built up and offline so
ultimately what this means is
we're not going to be running mapreduce
jobs or using a spark on top of
cassandra
cassandra is purely for low latency
request serving
and stuff that goes along with that
one of the one of my favorite shows is
the
chicago pd i'm from chicago so
you can see one of the progress
indicators down at the bottom
the little green bar just indicates that
hey you know i've only watched maybe
about
20 minutes 20 minutes of it so i still
have
some entertainment left
i'm sure you're kind of anxious to
see some of the specifics about
cassandra but we'll get there eventually
the the basic format of this is going to
be i'll
go over the old architecture then i'll
touch on where cassandra fits in the new
architecture
and then we'll take a little bit of a
look at the actual key space that we're
using in production
and how we how we actually migrated all
the existing data
and we have time i'll talk about some of
the operation
operational stuff that we encounter with
running cassandra
in production feel free to
interrupt at any point this is just a
guideline in case
you know you have some question i may
cover it in a innocent it's just the
idea of where we're at
so the old artifact the middle
architecture was
based on an isp web and so at the very
top
you can see we have google.com devices
and then some
some other internal services that aren't
exposed
to the internet that are just purely
within our data
so these are the three primary sources
of
web requests that come into a huge style
cubeshop itself is really just a python
application
we use a key event to make sure that
it's uh async
and we can handle a lot of traffic so as
you imagine
this service is one of our busier ones
at hulu
because there's a lot of people
constantly watching videos we're getting
updates on where people are in videos
we're also trying to service requests
for uh like the various trades that you
saw with the progress indicators
so there's a lot of uh a lot of
concurrency in here and
we use geometry with python to ensure
that we can handle
extremely high load now
in terms of the actual data stores
the two data data stores we use are
redis and originally was mysql
and the idea here is the redis shards
are there as uh pretty much casual now
we do
we did have persistence enabled but uh
you know we have a very large cluster
to handle a lot of that reload and
yeah it's it handles coordinated traffic
and then on the other side we have a
python application
that is talking to the mycl servers
and the actual mysql cluster consisted
of just
four really beefy you know big iron
machines with eight different shards
just very pure simple
sharding scheme you know we take a user
id
you know mod by four figure out what
actual machine is going to handle
that users traffic and then the
application goes connects
and gets all the data that it needs
also uh not a picture of that the uh
this is multivehicle so we have uh
master redis masters in one data center
and they replicate
two right slaves and another and the
same goes for the
mice two l shards we have uh mysql
masters and the same data as the
brightest masters and they replicate to
the other
just like brad
so the new architecture here's cassandra
um
you know we got rid of the there's not
much uh
different except for the bottom right
corner and
we got rid of my screw up and uh the
python application i was directly
talking to mysql
and we replaced it with a uh another api
that we uh called cassandra rest api so
if you appreciate
you'll get crappy so we have the crappy
idea
and uh in terms of the actual
storage uh we went from four mysql
servers up to eight cassandras
and there's actually eight in our first
data center and then eight in another
so they're fully replicated
and the reason why we switched to crabby
was because the python drivers at the
time
were not very good for cql and
at the point where we actually started
working on this
it was a toss-up between thrift and cql
but going forward
we really we realized that cql really
had
had a better future than the threat and
wanted to embrace that
and so we went ahead and created a very
thin api
just with the java the datastax java
driver
so we can use the cql
so any reason why you need a bigger
cluster for passenger than you used to
use for mysql
yes yeah very very good question one is
that we were running out of space with
the
mysql servers so we wanted to have a
little bit of extra headroom at that
point
and the other thing is replication
so with mice devel we only had
you know a master and then slaves there
wasn't three copies of the data but with
cassandra now we're going to hold
actually three copies on disk so we need
more actual hardware for that
um yeah the way that uh
i'll discuss a little bit about query
patterns but
the idea is that we do global forum
reads
we want to make sure that when the
data centers get cut off from each other
when they get isolated
there is no stopping this it's people
are going to continue to watch videos
and we really can't encourage any of the
standards so we need
a clear path of how we're actually going
to scale this
yeah mysql was working pretty well for
us but
you know the servers were reaching at 90
utilization
so we needed to get off as quickly as
possible
and also manually recharging is fun
said no one ever and yeah
in terms of uh continuing to use mysql
we would have had to
provision more hardware and then
redistribute all that data
and so we would have had a lot of work
ahead of us anyway instead of
going through that entire process we
said you know what let's just
switch to cassandra and put forth that
work to something
you know we can actually scale
continuously the
so the choice on cassandra as you can
probably imagine
and i'll show you shortly our data model
is actually pretty simple
there's not much complexity to
managing where people are in videos it's
very straightforward data
and uh it fit very well to cassandra you
know we looked at
hbase and a couple others and
there were drawbacks to all of we
initially did this hbase wasn't highly
available our hbase relied
on hdfs which
was not highly available due to the
single name issue
that's since fixed but uh yeah
too late so uh yeah i just didn't have
the performance we were looking for
one of the big things that we really
liked about the santa was that it was
highly available
and it's not just for the cases where
servers fail
it's really really nice to have a
database where we can
you know take a server offline upgrade
it
tweak some gc settings or make changes
without having to
totally take a master or slave offline
and going along with the entire idea of
cassandra you know
no node is special they're they're all
pretty much the same so you know it's
not like we have some sacred master
like we have with mysql where we can't
touch it at all it's
it's got to stay up because if it goes
down
we have a lot of work to recover
the complexity here is
with how reticent cassandra talk to each
other
and the basic idea is we have
two high-level queries that come you
have the actual video position updates
so the players on like the video players
on hulu.com and the devices
send beacons to huge stuff every 90
seconds or so
and then also whenever the player closes
so
we have this massive stream of position
updates that come in
and what happens there is first we write
it
directly into cassandra
and that's the entire right path
for the read path what ends up happening
is
firstly check rest
what ends up happening is that we have
to go hit cassandra
then cue a job and say okay you know
offline not offline but asynchronously
we have to go and update our product
cache and then we return the data
immediately to
the end user now why it happens
asynchronously is because
the work that we end up having to do to
update an entire user's
history in redis is way too long to do
our critical path so the user doesn't
want to have to wait
100 milliseconds for us to uh you know
update
that is when we have the data available
so we take that data
you know say okay we'll do this later
but
you know we return as soon as possible
as soon as
cassandra has them yeah
so in the old slide where we were using
my sequel we were using
yes so the uh we realized that
we really didn't want to rely on right
as a pure
data store sure it has persistence and
can handle
quite a bit of load but we were really
happy with the
persistence models there you know
there's uh
rdb and pendulum files or whatever
but they didn't have the same actual
durability
that cassandra could offer so we figured
let's not even use rest for that
persistence
instead we'll use cassandra purely for
the system persistence
and let the redis cluster act
simply as a cache
do you talk to this does it come back
anymore
uh yeah that's one of those yeah we
strive to maintain a
as close to the entire data set as
possible
which is allowed right
yeah just uh summing it up uh we have uh
you know apprentice is actually acting
as a cache
uh the main feature there is for uh
using its data structures
to have uh better indices
some of the indices are like you know
show me the last
five videos viewed by somebody
you know some extra information about
show metadata that sort of thing
and we can use hula with redis to uh
solve the joint issue that cassandra
doesn't have available
and when yeah the redis cluster you know
if you do a rolling restart and your
cluster
nodes go offline then you just rely on a
standard to rebuild the redis
so in radius node goes down
uh yes there would be a spike because
now instead of having
uh cash flow now everything starts
falling through to you at the same time
do you know yes yeah the uh setup is
that we have uh
64 bytes masters and 128
slaves i think so can we put a slave in
both data centers
uh yeah the way to think about it is
that cassandra stores the
raw data there's no there's no metadata
there's no
extra indices all of that extra data
is also added within redness
so we're not actually storing the
raw data
uh yeah the the model fits redis pretty
well
actually so you know we can have uh
various data structures that run the
single users
videos and sets and
all sorts of things within redis to make
it happen
so the data model within ryze is
actually a much more rich mechanism
negotiates that directly so yeah
when requests come in huge stop actually
makes the connections throughout us it
makes the connections look crappy
and the figures that i love
hadoop machines we had some spares
available
and we got
there were physical no vms
didn't want the overhead of uh having a
zen hypervisor or something sitting in
the middle we wanted to
actually have the jvm run directly on
the hardware
and uh just six hard drives uh nothing
special there
three two gigs of ram we're using level
of compaction
and just treating those six drives as a
jbod there was no rain
no software right now hard growth rate
it's very simple
and we ended up using level compaction
there
because we could get very good
distribution of data across all six
drives
we didn't have to worry about really
large ss tables building up from
size tier compaction or something we had
very little ones
almost yeah very evenly across all six
and this worked pretty well for the
rights
we had done a couple imports to test
performance
and we were very happy with the how the
whites were looking
but then we actually went to query the
data and
not so happy but i don't know what's
happening there is
there's a lot of disk i o that ends up
going on and
the disks simply couldn't keep up
because you know
you're you're learning to only 100
high apps or so with the standard drive
so
there just wasn't enough horsepower
available
to deal with it so
take two was to switch to ssds and
the approach here is that i
also went with the physical boxes but
the catch is we also realized that we
had to disable
c states so if you're familiar with
c-states
it's pretty much what your laptop does
but for servers
what your laptop does is when it's
sitting here it down-clocks the cpu so
really
you're only running at about 60 of the
power available
we want it to be at 100 if there's any
spare
spare time available we wanted to be at
full power
and kind of an interesting story there
is
being on the core team we're super
interested in minimizing the latency
because
all of our services are on the critical
path and with that
we kind of have a little competition
drawing within our team of
who could make their service the fastest
so
you know we improved things a lot we
started to look at our graphs
and as we started to reach peak hours
you know the rps the request per second
would start to go
but then latency would actually decrease
during peak hours
or like you know let's let's add more
traffic i mean like you know we can get
lower latency just by throwing more rps
at it
it's a big win what was actually going
on there was during peak hours the cpu
started to uh bump up their frequencies
and as soon as they did that the weights
started to go down
so instead of waiting until weak hours
to get low maintenance they
just automatically scale them to a 100
out of the box uh
yeah three and five consideration there
is that we want to tolerate failure
pretty well
it's way easier to rebuild that radio
rig with a single failed driving than it
is to let the camera
have to shuffle data around and
you know run a repair it's just if the
rate controller can
just copy the data from other local
drives
for sure uh we didn't end up going with
that because uh
as we start to calculate the replication
we have three replicas already times
another day
another data set so we have six
represents if we went
with the grade 10 all the time then we
end up with 12 copies of data on disk
which is pretty excessive
yep redis or sorry fabulous cassandra
fred is like swag too
cassandra likes a lot of ram for uh the
os
the os will eat all of it up for the
page cache and
uh make things faster just because the
os
will then hold data in ran and not have
to go to
the ssd's the feature so you
see that they use pretty much all
programs uh yes
if you uh yeah i don't have a graph here
but
you know we can watch the uh file system
buffer usage
uh over time and you can see it increase
very sharply as uh you know right after
the restart as
the ssp start pulling in more data it
gets held in ram so that way
any subsequent requests for that data
can just be serviced
out of ram other than hitting disk again
that question about the rebuilding of
raid 5 what kind of
terabyte size
all the hard drives you know you can
zero out the entire array in 15 minutes
or so
which is pretty good so we figured uh
under load
maybe an hour or maybe more but in terms
of
rebuilding with cassandra having to
stream it over the network from other
nodes
now it takes significantly longer
yes the key space design there's a
two different queries
two different sets of queries that we
want to handle one is
those queries that i was talking about
before
hey tell me the last position for
user x video live very very
straightforward
just have a simple views table
where the user id is the partition
and the video id is the clustering key
a couple attributes extra to store along
we just we thought about trying to use
a blob to hold all that data but
the issue with trying to hold it all as
a blob is
the modified write cycle like that you
may have just heard from the previous
presentation
and so with this if you actually split
up the individual
attributes then you can update them
individually not have to worry about any
using
modified lights
and the other case is
for a daily log that we had to provide
to another service
so part of our recommendation team
uh of all the views so that way they can
use this to train their models and
figure out the recommendations to use
for the next day
to incorporate it into any other of
their real-time services as well
and with mysql what we would do
is every single day we would run a
select star
from view videos and they would have to
scan through the entire data set on
all of the mysql servers and we had to
do this every single day
but mysql actually ended up taking 30
hours
to execute that query so that's a
real uphill about battle if you can't
even complete
the job on time
so the way that we approached it
this time was that every single day
we say okay there's going to be 120 rows
designated
for holding the views that come in
and so with these views uh or with all
those rows what we do is
we just have some very simple starting
scheme
where we write pretty evenly to all
three of them or
all 128 just as we will start to
mysql starters and this way
rather than say okay we just have one
row that holds
the entire day's worth of views
you know we split it up to 128 and we
get really even distribution
now in terms of actually querying it
we actually just do 128 little range
scans
and because the rows are spread across
nodes we can
actually distribute the load very evenly
so how many how many nodes do we have
eight yes eight and
right the five motivation for uh is
the rows get very large and we wanted to
try and keep them as small as possible
because when we do
do these select stars
they still end up returning a lot of
data and we can split it up into smaller
ones
and kind of prevent cassandra from
having to move
a lot of data these views are for the
username
so we just modify 128 and that
determines which of the 128 rows
is going to hold that particular user's
data for that day
so the next day we start a whole other
new 128
keep on going every single day and the
way it ends up working is that we have a
ttl
as well so pretty i don't know the exact
number i
am but eventually the old rows just
start dropping off the ttl clip
and
you know we get a lot of a lot of room
to play and we can change it every
single day
it's not like we're locked into 128 if
we realize
that these rows are too big we can just
say all right tomorrow we're going to
try 256.
and it actually only takes about five
minutes then to
query a day's worth of data so
big one uh
we're running so i'll skip over the
migration
migration was really simple uh the big
factor there is that we can exploit
time steps the common time steps to help
with consistency
so when we read
so you know we replicate data to the
cassandra cluster and then we have to
backfill
uh the data from mysql and cassandra and
if we
are very careful with the way we specify
the column timestamps
we ensure that all the new data that we
started writing to cassandra doesn't get
overwritten by the old data that comes
into
cassandra from mysql big thing there was
time
very helpful yes
operations operationally uh cassandra is
very smooth
too much issues use a
internal tool for automating your
repairs
every seven days we try and run a full
repair around the ring
and the standard gc time
dc preset within 10 days i think
um metrics
one of the cool things is with the
metrics library that cassandra uses is
that you can hook into it directly and
get access to
all the internal metrics i think there's
a blog post on
the data stacks blog about it but this
way we have access to
all the histograms for the latencies of
every single panel family on every
single node
as well as data sizes of the columns
families
number of connected users so forth it's
extremely helpful to have this there
when you're trying to troubleshoot
issues because you can pinpoint
the exact cause and dig into it very
very deeply because of the sheer number
of metrics
that it exposes but the big problem
there is it exposes
so many that it actually overwhelms
gravity
and yeah we
to give you an idea of how much data
there is originally we were
sending metrics from cassandra to grab
like internal metrics from cassandra
into graphite
once every 10 seconds and uh we were
sending roughly 10 megabytes per second
of metrics just a graduate
so the volume of data from
the metrics alone was a sizeable
fraction
of what some of the nodes were actually
dealing with for
the queries the
not very interesting i guess the
uh you can pretty easily tell if
something's going wrong if you look at
some of these
graphite graphs and see oh you know
there's an increase in
the number of tanks that some children
sees or is holding onto
and so it's super easy to
set alerts based on these
exceeds throughout building and so
having all the data available within
graphic makes it really easy for us to
use
existing tools
yeah so the parts that haven't been
smooth
for us with cassandra is uh we've run
into ss table corruption
a couple times and it hasn't been
hardworking
so there's been
a few bugs within cassandra but you have
to be very very careful
there's some race conditions and
also i know there's some instances early
versions of 2.0 that have
seen some corruption as well so
it's not 100 bulletproof and
when we do see it though there's two
tools that we go to
one is no tool scrub and the other is ss
table scrub
the first one no tool scrub pretty much
what happens is you can connect to a
live node
and that live node then itself executes
a snapshot and then
starts cleaning up the ss tables and
with ss table scrub you
do it offline so the node is actually
going to be down when you do that
the reason why i say that things are
really really bad um
you use as a table scrub is a couple
weeks ago
we ran into an issue where cassandra
wrote out a bad ss table
and as soon as it tried to read it it
was trying to allocate some very large
uh
bike bumpers and in doing so is causing
uh
javascript each face out of turning
errors and
as soon as it happened cassandra would
crash so every time he tried to restart
his sampling
crash again we had to
uh it's not lost so uh i'll go
the uh so as soon as when you run a
scrub it's also good to run a repair
so that way you know we have five other
copies of the data available
and then you can uh i thought because
this data is replicated immediately
right that means whatever
happened on one node
yeah the issue that we were seeing was
that santa simply couldn't read it
and so with that data
it's as good as being not there and
that's actually what that's
the scrum tools do is it simply just
gets rid of data
so via the
and finally there are things to watch
for
snapshots are awesome but they burn this
space
really really fast so with the no-till
scrub it doesn't snatch up
and then it rewrites all the tables and
if you know what a snapdragon does
it hard links all the existing files
and so initially you have no extra space
because really you just
the snapchat is a directory of hard
lines but when notification
starts copying the new files
then suddenly you have two copies of the
data and because of this
you want to make sure that you're always
under fifty percent disintegration
in case you ever have to uh do one of
those you want to make sure that you can
have a
type of other copy of your data sitting
around because uh
if not then you have to be very careful
with probably
cleaning up the snapshots as the scrub
is running or do it
compounding by column
and last slide
the performance of the cassandra is
really really good
but during our import the initial import
of micelle data and cassandra we
were running into some issues with the
gc and
we ended up figuring out some
settings that allowed us to get g1gc
to outperform a concurrent market suite
and
from the graph you can see that the
green line up top is
g1 gc and the bottom one
is cms and the graph
sorry it's small to read the graph is
us doing a small import of the entire
data we said
okay let's see how it performs let's try
and improve it
and we ended up running it for about
eight hours and with this
you know we can see that g1dc is
consistently
higher than cms and uh
we were pretty we were surprised with
how well performed actually because
cms is pretty much the go-to
garbage collector within java so it was
a good win for us